you I think had gotten an audition for
Mighty Ducks which was a big big movie
you passed the audition you got the role
your parents put the kill on it do you
throw a tantrum do you say cuz I could
have whined and cried my way into that
role I definitely remember like crying
on the kitchen counter right I mean
being like what like you guys are crazy
and did your sister even step in I mean
coach Aggie was like she's got a nice
voice
she was like laughing at haunting you I
don't even remember my sister in the
equation I don't even know where she was
she was like she really didn't care but
but like my parents were they were like
look you're about to enter junior high
school you got to get your education
that's the most important thing I
promise you you hate us now but you'll
thank us later and I was like and I do I
think them later because I think all
that movie stuff is meant more for
adults and I think you can mess you up
did you go see the film uh when you were
a kid I still have yet to see the film
Howard are you serious I have I hold
such right did you go see the film as a
kid I think I yes I did you liked it
killing us cuz you knew the part who got
your party Emilio Estevez got my part no
kidding I got your part um I don't know
if you know no I don't really don't know
what they don't kill you to go to the
MOOC did you say to your parents gonna
see this [ __ ] movie that I could have
been they're all gonna go mom and dad
yeah so you've never have you ever seen
the movie I think I have you have really
remember I would have made that would
listen when I was 11 years old if I
could have had a movie I imagined myself
where I'm watching a thousand times with
so much rage